[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablaremos de la crisis climática
podemos tener algo de Esperanza tras la
Cumbre del clima de Glasgow la Unión
Europea trata de abandonar la lucha
contra la crisis climática a través de
varias propuestas y Espera que para 2050
se convierta en la primera Región
climáticamente neutra del mundo estamos
aún a tiempo de salvar al planeta antes
de pasar al debate vemos Qué medidas se
han tomado hasta ahora a nivel europeo
la Unión Europea quiere ser la primera
Región climáticamente neutra del mundo a
partir de 2050 su objetivo es que la
temperatura no aumente más de 1,5 grados
centígrados para evitar un daño
Irreversible para el planeta para lograr
las metas ambientales la comisión
europea ha propuesto varias leyes que
reduzcan las emisiones contaminantes
entre ellas una que exija pagar a los
sectores que más contaminen como el de
la Aviación también se ha planteado
eliminar la dependencia del Carbón y de
los combustibles fósiles como la
gasolina o el diesel y se pedirá además
a los países del bloque utilizar el 30%
de los fondos de recuperación por
invertir en proyectos para la transición
ecológica la región ha visto claramente
las consecuencias de la crisis climática
en los últimos 40 años la temperatura
media en Europa aumentó drásticamente lo
que también ha provocado un incremento
de los fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
como las inundaciones que sufrieron el
pasado verano Bélgica Países Bajos y
Alemania donde murieron más de 500
personas sin embargo algunos colectivos
ecologistas entre ellos la joven líder
greta tómberg han criticado que las
medidas tomadas hasta ahora por parte de
la Unión Europea son insuficientes para
cumplir con los objetivos del pacto del
clima de París
y para entender un poco que se está
haciendo a nivel europeo ante la crisis
climática lo analizamos todo con la
eurodiputada del grupo de la izquierda
europea sirago bienvenida Sira Muchas
gracias y con el vicepresidente y
eurodiputado del grupo de Los verdes
arnés un arnés bienvenido Muchas gracias
Me gustaría empezar justamente contigo
arnés la Unión Europea aspira a ser la
primera Región del mundo con emisiones
netas 0 Pero antes en 2030 quiere
reducir al menos un 55% las emisiones
contaminantes es algo factible Sólo
quedan 9 años es algo que debería ser
factible e incluso podríamos ser más
ambiciosos si quisiéramos no yo creo que
Hemos llegado en esta legislatura los
temas climáticos están en el centro de
la agenda y esto es una buena noticia
recuerdo en el mandato anterior este 55%
de objetivo de reducción de emisiones se
nos votaba en contra en el pleno cuando
lo presentábamos es decir que la la Es
evidente pero es insuficiente no
nosotros necesitamos avanzar en la
descarbonización más rápido y por
ejemplo en las medidas de ejecución del
Green que se han presentado en el famoso
paquete fitford hay cosas que van
demasiado lento un 40% de objetivo de
renovables en 2030 no es suficiente
dejar por ejemplo de vender los coches a
motor de combustión en 2035 como ha
pedido la comisión es insuficiente nos
quedan muy pocos años para que la
temperatura no vaya más allá del grado y
medio y por lo tanto necesitamos correr
mucho más de lo que estamos haciendo
la Unión Europea comentábamos Espera a
tener ser climáticamente neutra en 2050
China ha dicho que en 2060 India ha
dicho que en 2070 es ya demasiado tarde
Como decía Ernest Yo creo que es
demasiado tarde en términos generales y
coincido con lo que ha dicho Ernest
requerimos muchísima más ambición en
términos generales y requerimos por
tanto medidas que nos ayuden que nos
acompasen porque aunque queda algo de
tiempo cada segundo cada es valioso
sobre todo porque yo creo que hay que
afrontar el debate de fondo el debate
estructural que requiere realmente un
cambio de paradigma sobre todo en
términos económicos que esto yo creo que
es el asunto de verdadera enjundia de
todo esto donde hay que entrar y yo creo
que en ese sentido y nosotros ahí somos
bastante críticos somos bastante
críticas creemos que no ha habido no hay
una voluntad política que realmente
repiense los modelos económicos hacia un
hacia elementos mucho más sostenibles y
yo creo que hay datos que hay que
observarlos bien porque al final la
cuestión de las emisiones tiene mucho
que ver con los países pero también las
emisiones per cápita que genera cada
país y ahí por ejemplo hay liderazgos
que nunca se señalan Como por ejemplo
Estados Unidos que es uno de los países
que más emite no es decir No solo es
china no solo es India es también y la
ue la propia u está en el cifras muy
altas de emisiones per cápita y a nivel
regional también a nivel geográfico por
lo tanto Bueno yo creo que son enormes
retos y sobre todo hay que profundizar
muchísimo más en las medidas porque si
no no vamos a ser capaces de llegar
aquí me gustaría tener una pregunta
justamente porque para los dos porque
estamos hablando de que hay que acelerar
esta transición ecológica pero en esta
transición mucha gente puede perder su
trabajo a menudo se critica que la
transición puede aumentar la desigualdad
es posible una transición justa como
evitar por ejemplo crisis como la de los
chalecos amarillos a ver la transición
ecológica solo funcionará con nuevo
contrato social no hay transición
ecológica sin nuevo contrato social no
es decir nosotros no podemos pensar que
determinados sectores económicos van a
sufrir una transición profunda que vamos
a ir a una descarbonización tan
acelerada como podemos sino construimos
también unas capacidades sociales de
absorber todo ello no y por eso nosotros
cuando hablamos de tránsitología
hablamos de Green por nosotros es un
nuevo contrato social y verde no y ahí
por ejemplo una de las cuestiones para
mí muy asociadas a la transición
ecológica es una Revolución fiscal en el
sentido necesitamos también que las
rentas del capital que hoy no
contribuyen al bienestar compartido
empiecen a contribuir no es decir esas
dos esos dos elementos son fundamentales
y después evidentemente necesitamos
apoyar determinados sectores que
evidentemente pues van a sufrir de la
transición ecológica no Y desde luego
pues pienso evidentemente las personas
que se dedican hoy actividades
directamente relacionadas en los
combustibles fósiles pues merecen apoyo
y ahí es verdad que los instrumentos de
la Unión Europea Como por ejemplo el
fondo de transición justa son a un
insuficientes no es una de las cosas que
también hemos dicho no que la transición
justa necesita que los mecanismos para
garantizarla se desarrollen más
ampliamente No Y ahí también es donde la
Unión Europea tiene que hacer mucho más
Sí yo coincido plenamente en que aquí la
gran conversación y yo creo que es una
conversación que está abierta una
conversación general es la conversación
en torno al pacto ecosocial esto es
fundamental y yo por Añadir alguna
cuestión más que creo que es básica para
la transición justa que yo creo que esto
es clave es la cuestión del modelo de
reindustrialización que requiere Europa
que es un elemento clave un modelo de
reindustrialización que tiene más que
tener en cuenta más las políticas de
demanda y no las políticas de oferta y
que plantee una planificación en torno a
lo que necesitan los pueblos que
formamos parte de Europa es decir
desplazar hacia esto no elementos
vinculados a los cuidados elementos
vinculados a la sostenibilidad y luego
un modelo de relaciones laborales yo
creo que todos estos son elementos
centrales que permiten sin duda alguna
plantear la transición en términos de
Justicia para que nadie se quede atrás
creo que además hay que señalar que hay
recursos suficientes Europa en este
momento dispone
recursos suficientes sobre todo si
planteamos que El Punto de partida sea
lo que ha señalado Ernest que es la
cuestión de una fiscalidad justa ahí
tenemos ingresos suficientes recursos
suficientes para poner en marcha un plan
que es necesariamente ambicioso pero que
es un plan que solo Será posible si se
hace con justicia yo creo que estos
elementos centrales falta ambición
política
sí falta mucha ambición política y sobre
todo falta mucho prioridades en agenda
que sean diferentes yo creo que está muy
bien que Europa pretenda liderar el
cambio y vamos y la reducción de
emisiones pero yo creo que Europa está
más interesada en liderar el cambio
tecnológico para garantizar la cuota de
beneficio determinadas multinacionales
asociadas a esto y yo creo que hay que
pensar más en la gente hay que pensar
más en los pueblos que formamos parte de
Europa y para eso se requiere mucha más
ambición política y sobre todo mucha
audacia porque cambiar un paradigma
económico y de convivencia no es algo
sencillo requiere mucho empuje mucho
impulso y muchas ganas justamente sobre
este liderazgo arnés existe este
liderazgo europeo realmente en la crisis
climática
y ahora que no podemos decir que la
Unión Europea no haya jugado un papel en
las negociaciones internacionales
positivo en algunos ámbitos pero por
ejemplo algo que nosotros nos hubiera
gustado es que en la Cumbre de Glasgow
las contribuciones europeas y nacionales
hubieran sido mucho más ambiciosas es
decir porque después en el problema es
que nosotros como europeos no somos lo
suficientemente ambiciosos estamos en
una mala posición para exigirle al resto
del mundo a China o a India que lo sean
mucho más no y te pongo un ejemplo no no
hemos sido capaces en la Cumbre de
Glasgow de fijar una meta Clara para
salir de los combustibles fósiles y de
sus subvenciones no entre todos porque
la India que es muy dependiente de los
combustibles fósiles no ha querido pero
cómo lo decimos nosotros a la India que
acelere la descarbonización y
la afinación de sus combustibles fósiles
cuando aquí no tenemos un calendario
claro para terminar con ellas no
entonces este tipo el liderazgo europeo
se construye con una agenda más creíble
dentro no y ahí yo creo que hay
muchísimo camino por recorrer Europa
será más fuerte en las negociaciones
climáticas cuando su agenda sea más
seria
sobre la Cumbre del clima de Glasgow
podríamos hablar en términos de éxito de
fracaso a menudo se habla de las cumbres
en estos términos como la considerarías
yo creo que no ha salido bien lo que
pasa es que hay una cuestión que es
contradictoria y es que tampoco parece
que las expectativas fueran muy altas y
la verdad es que esto debería
entristecernos profundamente a todos y
todas porque es verdad que aquello que
se dice constantemente Nos quedamos sin
tiempo Aunque todavía estemos a tiempo
de hacer muchas cosas digamos que es un
evento o es un pequeño es un momento
perdido en el que deberíamos haber
salido con muchas más acuerdos más
ambiciosos y mucho más estructurales
nosotros desde luego consideramos que no
se han alcanzado los objetivos que se
tendrían que haber alcanzado
estoy de acuerdo con siren que no no ha
salido como queríamos lo que no debe
llevarnos a decir que las que estas
Cumbres no sirven para nada en el
sentido de que al final El marco que
tenemos es el marco multilateral de
negociaciones para luchar contra el
cambio climático no tenemos otro es este
y estas Cumbres evidentemente sí que
sirven lo que pasa es que un poco a la
raíz de lo que decía si era que estoy de
acuerdo en los resultados de esta Cumbre
hubieran sido válidos para 10 años atrás
no si 10 años atrás hubiéramos tenido
estos resultados diríamos Bueno pues
vamos en el buen camino no es totalmente
insuficiente lo que ha salido de Glasgow
lo que debe llevarnos no a decir que la
Cumbre las cumbres no sirven sino que la
Cumbre del año que viene porque ahora es
verdad que una de las cosas positivas de
Glasgow es que los compromisos
nacionales se van a revisar cada año y
esto de alguna forma pues es momento
positivo lo que debe llevarnos es a
movilizarnos y a trabajar más para que
la Cumbre del año que viene tenga
resultados mejores ya para acabar me
gustaría preguntaros estamos aún a
tiempo
yo creo que sí Y además yo creo que es
imprescindible que lancemos siempre un
mensaje de esperanza y de ilusión
de movilización para que
todos y todas nos impliquemos en el
cambio Es decir esto es fundamental
desde luego tiene hay un instrumento que
tiene que ver con la política que es
clave que es fundamental pero desde
luego tiene que haber una acción
colectiva también exigiendo que haya
cambios de fondo hay tiempo tenemos que
cambiar muchas cosas pero pero yo creo
que es importantísimo que no perdamos el
pulso para que el cambio llegue cuanto
antes porque desde luego lo que no vale
lo que no es negociable lo que no es una
opción es la desmovilización o caer en
la desesperanza porque nos lleva
posiciones catastrofistas que yo creo
que no tienen ningún sentido
Totalmente de acuerdo con Yo siempre
digo lo mismo no el Green Day europeo no
Sería posible sin Friday for Future No
tendríamos grindile europeos y los
jóvenes no hubieran salido a la calle e
insisto lo que decía antes no en el
mandato anterior cuando nosotros
presentábamos enmiendas en el primer
parlamento europeo para que la Unión
Europea fijara menos 55% de emisiones en
2030 el pleno votaba en contra los
grandes grupos nos votaban en contra hoy
Esto es político oficial de la Unión
Europea porque los jóvenes han salido de
la calle no es suficiente desde luego
pero la movilización funciona sirve hay
que trabajar políticamente hay que
movilizarse Y eso es lo que creo que la
llamada que tenemos que hacer a los que
queremos combatir al cambio climático es
a seguir trabajando y no y no
desfallecer hay tiempo y hay que seguir
peleando perfecto muchas gracias arnés
estira ha sido muy breve pero intenso
Muchísimas gracias a los dos y a ustedes
les esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver France 24 en
español
[Música]